[Music]
in a world exhausted of fossil fuels
solar panels can provide a sustainable
solution to our energy problems but they
also come with a couple of issues for
one solar farms are massive and they
have to be set up somewhere that gets a
lot of sunlight now if only we had a
large mass of unused land that gets
guaranteed sunlight every day hmm
could we cover an entire desert in solar
panels would that be enough to power the
entire world this is what if and here's
what would happen if we covered the
Sahara Desert with solar panels if we
cover just 1.2 percent of the Sahara
Desert and solar panels we can harness
enough power to meet the energy needs of
the entire world how would we overcome
the geopolitical and financial obstacles
involved and how could this project
thoroughly change the deserts climate
usually a solar farm is built to prevent
changes in the environment but if we
built one in the Sahara it might cause
some changes of its own if we line the
desert floor with giant solar panels it
would double the rainfall in the region
an increased vegetation cover by about
20 percent sound a little unbelievable
well let me explain Sahara sand is
unusually light in color which means it
tends to reflect a lot of light and heat
back up into the air if we covered the
sand in dark solar panels it would mean
that more Sun would be absorbed and the
ground temperature would increase warmer
air rises to areas in the atmosphere
where it's cooler and moisture there
condenses and falls as rain before you
knew it one of the most extreme climates
on earth would undergo a significant
makeover so if the solar panels would
not only provide sustainable energy
solutions but also add much-needed
greenery to our largest desert then what
are we waiting for
shouldn't we be out there building these
things already well it's a little more
complicated than that
one thing it's great to produce enough
energy to power the world but then you
have to worry about how you're gonna get
it to everyone the most likely place
this energy would travel to first is to
Europe exporting sustainable energy
would do great things for a lot of
African economies but would they have
the means to do it
currently electrical grids in Africa
aren't very reliable and they need power
lines of around eight hundred to three
thousand kilometres to get where they
needed to go transporting power over
long distances leads to power loss of up
to ten percent which means that an
already expensive project would get even
more pricey and where would all the
money come from Africa is home to quite
a few unstable governments the kind that
raised some pretty big red flags with
investors of multi-billion dollar
projects like this one on top of that
this would be a long-term project so
there'd be a lot of moving parts
several countries would have to be
involved and any one of them might see a
changing political landscape over the
years that could disrupt or put an end
to the whole thing as great as this
project would be it would probably be
better to attempt it on a small scale
first
maybe solar panels could be used to
power some small African villages and
help to spread access to electricity but
that's a topic for another what-if